en 1996 mariaelena carvajal dio a luz a
su cuarto hijo fue un día de alegría
pero también de una tristeza profunda
cuando el pequeño fue raptado los
médicos lo presionaron para que se
dejara esterilizar de lo contrario no lo
volvería a ver y a la fuerza fue
sometida a cirugía me preguntaron si me
cuidaba con algún método le dije que no
puesto que me había casado de mi esposo
decía que las mujeres de la calle se
cuidaban más su esposa no tendría por
qué usar ningún método por ende no usaba
entonces me dijeron de que señora no es
necesario que usted pide permiso su
esposo entonces le dije no es mi esposo
no va a querernos entonces me dijo
señora si usted ya tiene cuatro hijos
que piensa tener más hijos como el cual
el caso de maría elena también lo vivió
nancy sánchez en 1999 quien bajo los
efectos de la anestesia fue esterilizada
en el hospital donde dio a luz entonces
le pregunté a la señorita qué pasó
porque tengo ese corte
entonces me dijo no es que ya se te mete
al hígado sí señora me dice además me
dijo yo voy a hacerle lino y el gobierno
no está para mantener a mucha gente
maría elena y nancy son apenas dos
víctimas de miles que llevan más de dos
décadas esperando justicia por las
esterilizaciones forzadas a las que
fueron sometidas durante el gobierno del
entonces presidente alberto fujimori es
como si las trescientas veinte mil
mujeres esterilizadas y los 16.000 a 22
mil hombres no sabemos exacta de la
cifra de hombres que fueron también
esterilizados mediante la vasectomía no
le importará a ningún gobierno de los
cinco que han pasado en estos 25 años es
así es una certeza de duele que
vergüenza en 1995 fujimori promovió un
programa de planificación familiar
llamado anticoncepción voluntaria
quirúrgica como medida para combatir la
pobreza pero en realidad fue un
procedimiento forzoso traumático y hasta
hoy en día
o secuelas físicas y sicológicas a todas
las víctimas